foreign
welcome to Hannity wow hello how are you
welcome this great audience of ours what
a great crowd all right big news tonight
they didn't arrest Donald Trump today
they arrested somebody else what a
shocker anyway three felony counts again
zero experienced Hunter Biden but
interestingly no tax charges no money
laundering indictments no fair Avail
right thank you no fair violations or
public corruption crimes instead the
special counsel David Weiss indicted
Hunter on three gun crimes uh now first
of all I'm not happy that anyone ever
gets arrested nothing to be happy about
uh but let me tell you what I'm really
angry about that's Justice not being
served and don't get me wrong these are
serious charges and you know what if you
believe in equal justice application of
our laws everyone else all of you here I
promise if you did what Hunter did you
would be charged and by the way these
crimes can carry over 20 plus years in
prison oddly enough out of all the
egregious you know issues that we have
been investigating involving Hunter
Biden in foreign countries and tens of
millions of dollars and and show
corporations
etc etc being paid with no experience uh
this gun incident is the only one that's
not connected to Joey the big guy his
father in other words this this is the
low hanging fruit take a look
that's one of about a dozen crimes the
hunter Biden's committed and ironically
that's the one crime
that he committed that you cannot tie
Joe Biden into so we'll see what happens
with the other 11 or so crimes that the
president's son's committed but it
sounds like you're still expressing the
skepticism here I mean the idea that you
you know you you wanted an indictment
from your perspective here that's not
enough an indictment for uh money
laundering violation of the foreign
agents registration Act tax evasion the
list goes on and on uh you've never
heard me say anything about gun charges
now Congressman Comer is right let's be
clear even though these gun charges were
never supposed to happen now why is that
because the fix we now know was in from
the get-go and by the way for both
bidens in fact plan a if you will was
going pretty well for a good while for
five long years the doj's David Weiss
sat on Hunter Biden's case as the IRS
whistleblowers told us the FBI
whistleblower told us yeah he was being
treated very differently than than any
other person but they purposely in this
case allowed the statute of limitations
to expire on extremely serious tax
violations and then he planned to charge
Hunter with absolutely nothing sweeping
all of this misconduct under the rug
like a bad dream that is until several
IRS and FBI whistleblowers they came
forward uh oh plan a is blowing up right
before their eyes and they alleged all
the special treatment for Hunter and
accused Weiss Garland and or both of
lying about their ability to charge
Hunter with a crime now that's when
Weiss and Hunter's attorney they all got
together all right time now for Plan B
that was the backup strategy that's the
one that involved the unprecedented
sweetheart slap on the wrist plea
agreement for Hunter no felonies no jail
time and most importantly uh Hunter was
given immunity no charge that could
implicate pops it was the broad immunity
deal buried deep into the gun diversion
portion of the plea agreement on page 15
along with an apparent off the books
agreement to sweep everything else under
the rug and once again it was all going
along perfectly until that you know
rascally federal judge did her job and
didn't just rubber stamp the plea
agreement and started asking questions
and raising real concerns at one point
my favorite moment the judge says to the
prosecution have you ever seen a
diversion agreement that is so broad
that it encompasses crimes in in other
cases prosecutor had to answer no your
honor I've never I've never seen a deal
like this then why did they offer that
sweetheart deal anyway Plan B now dead
so today this was plan C they didn't
want to go to plan C they want to plan a
and they want a plan B after trying so
hard to protect the bidens from any
legal scrutiny for years well Weiss was
promoted a special counsel by the
Attorney General Merrick Garland in this
role Weiss is now able to stall and
Stonewall any public information
requests but he still has to answer to
federal judge and that's Mary Ellen
naraka and she offered Weiss ordered
Weiss to make a charging decision on the
gun portion of the failed plea deal by
the end of the month that's why it
happened today so here we are three
felony gun charges against Hunter Biden
but only after allegations from multiple
whistleblowers otherwise this all would
have been swept under the rug several
ongoing investigations in Congress a
federal judge who refused to rubber
stamp the doj's prosecutorial misconduct
and now the obvious question will
special counsel David Weiss charge
Hunter with any other serious crimes
here's the answer I tend to think not
why because unless he's forced to less
more whistleblowers come forward or
something else unforeseen happens so
long as Joe Biden is the presumptive
2024 nominee for the Democratic party we
know that Weiss and Garland will do
everything they can to protect the
bidens and will never charge Hunter with
a crime that in any way will implicate
his president father that's why this is
a politicized and weaponized Department
of just this now for them beating up
Donald Trump is so much more important
more superseding indictments let's
indict Trump another four times let's
arrest them another four times let's
take get four more mug shots by the way
what about upholding the rule of law I
thought Lady Justice was supposed to be
blind Equal justice equal application of
our laws simply put and this is the
simple truth
the system is rigged you have a corrupt
Department of Justice and they are on a
political Mission this has always been
about protecting Joe Biden so he can
beat Donald Trump or any other
Republican uh and nobody in the
Democratic party nobody in this justice
department really seems to care about
Hunter at all you know what he'll be the
sacrificial lamb here they're more than
happy to charge him with a hundred gun
crimes but don't even think about fairer
violations or tax evasion or money
laundering or bribery because none of
those allegations exist without the big
guy no one in Russia no one in China no
one in Ukraine Kazakhstan new Romania
you think they'd be sending Hunter tens
of millions of dollars if daddy wasn't
elected to the highest levels of the
federal government Hunter admitted
himself I don't know maybe because my
dad's the president he had no experience
in energy oil gas if I you know or or
Ukraine why'd you get paid I don't know
you know it's also highly unusual that
nine Biden family members I'd like to
know what the grandchildren did to
receive the money they got from foreign
Nationals in China and Russia Ukraine
what did the grandkids do it's also
highly unusual isn't it that Hunter is
on record complaining about giving up
half his income to Pops and paying for
the upkeep of Joe's Delaware mansion out
of these different accounts when he
would ask the the head of Rosemont
seneca's finances so clearly all of the
alleged crimes aside from the gun
charges stem from Hunter's relationship
to Daddy and based on that 110-23 form
that the FBI informant well Hunter sold
more than access at least one credible
FBI Source talking to the CEO of Barista
the big oil and gas giant Ukraine
believes the Biden's actually sold
foreign policy decisions that's what the
FBI informant was told that would be
called bribery and while many in the
media mob are more than happy to follow
Biden's marching orders and and put
their heads in the sand and take their
talking points from this guy Ian Sam's
out of the War Room that they built out
of the White House counsel's Office well
House Republicans are simply following
the facts and today one proud journalist
was just not ready to face these facts
take a look
do you believe the president lied to the
American public when he said he'd never
talked to his son about business
dealings
yes or no it's all right
you can't answer that
do you believe when they said the
president went on conference calls do
you believe that happened
okay do you believe the president went
to Cafe Milano and had dinner with the
with the clients of Hunter Biden who
believes he got those clients because he
was selling the brand
okay do you believe Hunter Biden when
you saw the video of him driving a
Porsche that he got a hundred and forty
three thousand dollars to buy that
Porsche the next day
do you believe the three million dollars
from the Russian oligarch that was
transferred to the Shell companies that
the bidens controlled after the dinner
from Cafe Milano took place
okay then I go back do you think the
president lied that he when he said
well you want you want to know I'm not
saying impeachment all I'm saying is I
would like to know answer these
questions the American public ought to
know and that's what impeachment inquiry
provides anyone who says there's no
evidence of wrongdoing and Corruption
right is a liar and totally or and or
totally ignorant or simply just
political hacks like at msdnc or fake
news CNN now we have photographs we have
texts we have emails we have bank
records we have suspicious activity
reports and show corporations and
eyewitness accounts all the evidence
shows sketchy corrupt individuals
forking over what is ultimately tens of
millions of dollars to the Biden family
in return phone calls meetings dinners
direct access to the big guy and maybe
even policy decisions according to the
1023 form and literally nothing else no
one was paying Hunter Biden for his
experience or intellect he didn't have
any of either this was a guy struggling
with addiction he was not reliable had
very little expertise in anything at
that point in his life sadly other than
drugs and yet Millions poured in thanks
to the brand and the brand of course was
not Hunter it was the big guy the
President Joe Biden then vice president
it's past time for Joe Biden to be held
accountable don't expect any justice
from Joe Biden's weaponized doj hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else